hi guys i want to talk about blood
sugars i want to talk about what is a
normal blood sugar um
well typically it's between 80 and 100
milligrams per deciliter
sometimes it could be 70 if you're you
know it can go down if you're completely
giving up sugar can go even lower
and that's a total normal situation now
what does this mean
80 to 100 milliliters per deciliter
basically that means
the ratio of how much sugar that you
have in your blood now an average person
of 165 pounds
has one in one-third gallons of blood in
their body okay
a gallon and one-third of a gallon of
blood
um and the if it was normal let's say it
was 90 okay right in the middle that
would be kind of a heaping
slightly more than a teaspoon not quite
a heaping but slightly a little bit more
than a teaspoon of sugar
per all this blood
okay that's
if we diluted that that would be
90 okay that would be normal blood
sugars
and you can actually convert
protein and even fat into sugar so you
don't even need carbs
to get this normal ratio
but an average american consumes
31
teaspoons of sugar every single day
that's
130 to 145 pounds of sugar a year
in an average lifetime
it's a dumpster full of sugar
now this is why
most of the population is becoming
pre-diabetic and
diabetic
and the problem is they don't know that
they're actually
a diabetic yet or they don't know
they're a pre-diabetic because
it's not showing up on the blood test
okay
it won't show up because it starts off
small and it gets worse and worse and
worse and then one day you have it
okay but some of the symptoms are um you
know you get tired after you eat
you crave sweets you ha you're not
satisfied after you eat you can't go
many hours without eating and then when
you eat you feel better that's a
pre-diabetic situation
but
you don't need a lot of sugar in your
diet to have a normal blood sugar in
fact i recommend you go zero sugar
and your sugars will be you will clear
up so many health problems if you do
that okay so
here's two two points i want to make you
don't need sugar okay like some people
say well doesn't your brain run out of
sugar no it can run on fat it can run in
other fuels
your body does not need sugar all right
put your comments below and i'll see in
the next video
hey guys thank you so much for watching
i really appreciate it please click the
share button below and i will see you in
the next video